[Music]
let me get a little more coffee go get
some coffee go get some coffee stretch
i'll get a little more coffee
okay
right over there take me over the top
yeah
can you tell me what's in that coffee is
it just coffee is it what kind of
special is there like an egg cracked in
there do you have hot pepper is it
brewed in
why why do you ask that because i don't
know
pepper and an egg
is that is that a crazy thing to ask now
hold on a second no there was a moment
it's not a crazy thing now this
[ __ ] was drinking coffee that
also had egg in it no
what and coffee and eggs hold on a
second what was the thing what was that
coffee what was the bullet coffee that's
butter it's like a bunch of spring it's
a butter okay well grandfather uh bullet
coffee uh which is otherwise known as an
actually known as bulletproof coffee
uh is uh
is coffee and butter and mct oil uh and
sometimes coconut oil there's different
ways to make it but the main thing that
bulletproof coffee is by the way that's
not pepper okay that might sound strange
but like by the way i never really i did
the bulletproof coffee thing for like
five seconds it's just absolutely right
destroyed my stomach yes i'm not i hate
it
the reason i was asking was because it's
not that crazy to assume that to go from
butter to an egg i don't know no you
know what i i have uh coffee with my
eggs all the time and i've never thought
to like stir the eggs straight into the
coffee
i could be missing out i mean that's a
very complicated thing get some eggs
have a cup of coffee that's that's i'm
down to try it i'm down to try to like
you know a coffee egg would be a coffee
that's been hard-boiled an egg that's
been hard-boiled in a pot of coffee that
would be good that would be a god that
would be a coffee egg but i would chop a
coffee
yeah like in a percolator right where
you're actually boiling let's make both
of those and then see which ones there's
that's something that a tea is a thing
but wait wait no it's getting tea but
the the coffee's not going to penetrate
the shell of the egg and actually affect
the flavor so yes it is
he's so sure of this such
i mean you were so clear i'm so sure
that that oh yes it will it most
certainly will you know it's like you
work
how is it going to penetrate the shell
of the egg by the way i love your
passion for this i really do i have no
idea
there really is i have no idea because i
i've had a tea egg before i've had a tea
egg which was an egg that you're kidding
boiled in tea and it was delicious it
tasted like tea yeah
very good i hear blowing my mind never
heard of that a tea egg yes what is this
it's a it's from the other cultures
what culture japan
oh
and chinese chinese chinese
i don't really i don't know chinese tea
eggs
yes chinese tea eggs and then mine do
they
will you find it in a savory liquid star
anise well that's why you eat sticks and
peppercorns
star and but uh do they peel the egg
before they boil it
that's what we need to know you can't
peel it
before you boil
i have a special treat for you today you
do which is i this morning
i hard-boiled these eggs in coffee no
[ __ ] way oh no to see whether uh it
would get through so if you guys want to
peel these eggs and then taste them yeah
yeah let's do it
let's do it you didn't peel it before
you boiled it i did not peel okay so you
just you just boiled
you just i made a pot of coffee and then
i put the eggs into the coffee with no
extra water just the coffee
and then i boiled them as i standardly
do hard-boiled eggs
do you have salt there's no yeah there's
no brown coloration in here though like
with the tea what do you say the tea the
shells are still smelling they still
smell like eggs
see here's what that's i think the tea
egg the thing with the tea egg and i
don't know how you can never peel these
well do you guys suck i suck at peeling
harder you gotta use the side of your
thumb these are tough the scissors these
are tough they're shattering into a
billion pieces um i'm not good at this
i would say that i think maybe let's
look up how the t egg is cooked but i
think
what i meant to say when i
did uh look that up and actually they
soak it in tea after they hard boiled
after they boil it so oh
so so this is gonna be nothing it's
probably not gonna taste like coffee
this is gonna taste like it smells like
an egg it just tastes like an egg yeah
oh does it so yeah well i like the shell
right so so we gotta do it the way they
do the tea you gotta soak it in coffee
you gotta and this is what i meant
when i said do you peel it first you
gotta boil it peel it
and then soak it in some coffee and soak
it but definitely boil it first before
you peel it
well megan thank you
very much
my husband was like what are you doing
and i was like i'm working i'm working
here guys wait wait for those freaks out
there let's do a little asmr
why
stop
stop oh my god no you don't
you actually does not bother me that
doesn't bother me that doesn't bother
you wait let me do it let me see if i
can it won't bother me if you're doing
it on purpose
really
right that's what we established chewing
sounds don't bother me it's not the
sound
it's not it's that it's that people
don't give a [ __ ] yes yes it's the it's
the chaos it's the the psychology behind
it being like i don't care what sounds i
make that are invading this space sounds
very odd because the sound bugs the [ __ ]
out of me
and whether you are doing it
intentionally or not it's the sound so
this bothers you
yes it does
you know what i'm doing on purpose
uh-huh yeah you're trying bob there's a
lot of people out there right now that
are [ __ ] really grossed out and then
there's some people that are getting
erections right right right
right
yeah i guess you know i don't know is
that what it is
are women into this mega they're getting
turned on it's only
though
yes i do meg speaks for a woman
it's a good egg meg thank you yeah
that's a good egg that's good coffee
yeah and these drinks so it turns out
you can boil your egg and coffee or
water and it won't penetrate the shell
boil it and whatever whatever you're
already boiling just go ahead and throw
an egg in there
it won't make a difference
you